The joe rogan experience.
David Seaman who was on the podcast last week had a really interesting take on
coin that I thought it was kinda funny.
Um,
he was saying that if,
if bank,
like Bank of America for site,
if they were smart,
they would get involved in bitcoin.
He was like,
you already have this established name brand.
Like cryptocurrencies are going to be here.
They're,
they're,
they're here to stay.
This is his take.
He's like,
why wouldn't you capitalize on the name brand that you've already built in on
and get on the mark and quick get in on it now in the early days and establish
like that Bank of America like still has uh,
like a footing in,
in this as well as in regular money.
And he was like,
it would be a really wise investment.
I think you're going to see that happening.
Um,
in short time really,
um,
we saw this with the Internet,
which was at first the telecommunications companies fought tooth and nail.
They could not believe that a decentralized packet switch network like the
Internet would deliver quality,
voice and quality video.
They wanted to build highly controlled and structured networks.
Um,
and they tried to fight it because it,
it threatens and long distance market,
which was very lucrative.
It threatened many other markets.
Today,
three quarters of all international calls happen on Skype.
Three quarters,
three quarters.
That's,
that's a market that a few,
you know,
two decades ago was,
uh,
15,
$20 billion market and disappeared.
Um,
and essentially they had to restructure operations.
Now they made up for it.
The smart ones became very good as Internet service providers and created whole
new businesses.
The replace those lost revenues.
So,
so what happened there is you have these telecom companies trying to fight it
until some of the smaller ones,
some of the ones that don't have solid,
entrenched positions and can't take advantage of size.
Thank,
you know what we've,
I'm going to cut off from this herd and go play with that bit bitcoin a bit.
And as soon as that starts happening,
there's almost a stampede because everybody tries to rush into it.
That's what happens with telecommunications.
The smaller providers started peeling off from the herd and instead of fighting
it,
they started trying to build service providers.
So it's really just a matter of who runs first,
right?
Someone's going to start running and then right.
And then the first breaks apart because until the first one breaks,
everyone's like,
well,
we were too serious for this bitcoin stuff.
And they're looking over their shoulder trying to make sure that everybody else
is also staying away from it.
But eventually the market dynamic changes.
So it's just essentially,
it's just human nature,
like with human nature this to certain rules that are just always going to be
into place,
play hard to get and follow the leader.
Those are two big ones.
Yeah.
And bitcoin threatens some business structures within the banking industry.
It May,
it's gonna make it difficult for them to charge exorbitant fees to do
international wire transfers when you can do it cheaper.
Just like if you have Skype,
you can't $3 a minute long distance calls and,
but at the same time,
the smart bankers are looking at this and their thing.
Yeah.
But if we have a cheap,
efficient,
secure payment system,
we can build some really interesting things on top of that and create whole new
businesses that are very competitive that can actually give us a lead.
So we,
our alge run the heard the,
you know,
disruption in a competitive market is actually very,
very enticing to the,
to the second and third tier players because they don't have an advantage.
They're too small to compete against the big guys.
But if they see this disruptive technology,
I think,
well maybe if I hit your ride on that I'm going to overtake everybody.
Um,
and you know,
I can be the blockbuster or I can be the Netflix,
I can be the tower records or I can be the iTunes.
And we've seen this happen in technology races before.
Yeah,
that's fascinating.
How people,
some people just don't want to buck the trends they did.
They don't want to go along with the flow of things or they want to buck the
trends.
They want to somehow or another figure out a way where they can prove everybody
else wrong.
And VHS is making a comeback.
And you know,
renting movies is still valid.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot of those fuckers out there that just won't let it go.
Radio companies change is scary.
Yeah.
It is scary.
But that's,
that's a,
that's the nature of the beast.
Especially today when we're involved in the craziest time for change the world
has ever known.
Yeah.
Um,
there at the moment,
being on the top of an industry,
especially an industry that's involved in technology is a very precarious
position.
You know,
if you talked to,
um,
Kodak a decade ago,
do you think they would,
they would realize that suddenly it's the largest vendor or manufacturer of
cameras in the world would be a telephone company.
Nokia,
within three years became the world's largest maker of cameras and suddenly the
entire industry changed.
Right.
And how do you compete against that?
They're not even in your industry.
They just came out of left field.
It's like you're suddenly the horse buggy manufacturer and forward is taking
your business and you never expected that was going to happen.
Well,
Nokia has a camera phone now,
a windows phone.
That is some insane amount of pixels.
It's like 40 fucking megapixels or something.
Something crazy.
41 41 megapixel says Jamie,
Jamie's on top of that shit.
41 fucking megapixels on a phone.
I mean this thing I think has have the note three,
I think it has 12 or something.
You know,
it's better than that.
Are you familiar with Moore's law?
Yes.
So,
so for,
for your listeners to Moore's law,
it was created by Gordon Moore processors,
right?
Processing speed and yeah.
And what he said was that he estimated that because of the way silicon works
every 18 months,
the speed of a computer with double or the price would drop by half.
And that has been true now for more than 25 years.
Wow.
And,
and that thing then plays out in camera megapixels,
in storage on SD cards in the size of the,
of your smartphone,
in the,
a number of sensors you can put into the smartphone.
And it's battery.
Battery life is the one that's lagging behind.
And it's the main thing that's holding back this technology.
Moore's law also applies to things like bitcoin.
It also applies to networks like the Internet and what it means is that if
you're in an industry that's established and suddenly you have a competitor
that's coming at you with the power of Moore's law,
you better watch out because you're in,
it's not a matter of whether you will be able to compete in a decade.
It's a matter of whether your industry will still exist in a decade.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Isn't that fascinating?
That whole industries can just vanish
150 years of Kodak and then suddenly film doesn't exist.
Gone in the decade.
Do you remember when you used to have to pay money for long distance?
You know,
long distance calls don't exist.
Like you can call New York right now and your home phone and it's regular call
on your cell phone.
It's totally normal.
Like if you used to call long distance on a cell phone,
it was an exorbitant amount of money.
Saturday afternoons,
London payphone.
When I was a student,
I would go there with a stack of coins that was probably about $10 worth in
today's money.
I would sit in a payphone and my family would know what time I was going to call
coordinated.
I'd call in,
they'd be a line of 15 relatives sitting,
standing behind the phone on the Athens side and would be,
hi mom,
I love you very much.
Hi Dad.
I love you very much,
Hasis.
It's all awesome.
Okay,
next aunt,
aunt Maria.
Julie Ann's what?
London is awesome.
And I'm stuffing coins as fast as I can into this pay phone.
And then you know,
four or five minutes later,
$10 down the drain,
and I've said hello to the entire family and that's all I could afford.
Wow.
That was my experience.
And now you could Skype for hours for free and not crazy.
Yeah.
Look at a video of each other,
talking to each other through your laptop for free.
Wow.
Fascinating,
fascinating times.
When you put it in that kind of a perspective,
you really sort of understand the change.
They just,
the ability that we have to reach out to each other is just unprecedented in
human history.
It's never been even remotely close to what it is now.
I saw somebody walking down the street the other day skyping with someone while
they were walking on the street and they were talking while they're walking down
the street.
They're like,
yeah,
so we're going to blah,
and then the other person's on the other end.
I'm looking at their phone.
I'm like,
this is crazy.
They're doing it through a cell phone connection.
I'm doing that all the time now.
Yep.
Walking down the street through a cell phone connection,
streaming video back and forth to each other.
It's amazing.
Amazing.
Okay.